so here's this billionaire with a
thousand followers which is a perfect
segue into my next question we're
talking about your uncle billionaire
right
no social media presence okay you know
by the way just to give him a a little
uh stature so they understand he made
his money as a developer in crescent
heights which is the biggest condo
conversion company i think in the world
uh he is the what chairman of the board
of norwegian cruise lines if you're ever
in miami and you want to take your kid
to the local jcc
it's the russell freaking galvet jcc
meanwhile he's got no social media
presence you wouldn't know any of this
which leads me to my next question it's
not like you're massive
on instagram i mean you're doing okay
you maybe got like 5 000
right a little more maybe six more i
don't know maybe it's seven okay all
right check you're under 10 000. so in
this world that we're living in right
now that is so based on social media and
social media you got clout bro got a
million followers
but behind the scenes what are they
doing you know how do you grapple with
not being a big person out there
on social media
but your you know your pocket books are
fat but not necessarily your social
media clout do you ever say like dude
what is this clown with a million
followers like how do you balance
actually having money and being
successful being a multi-millionaire and
just not having a major social media
presence so i love social media i
actually think it is the best marketing
thing that came out and i think it's
made many people very successful and
very wealthy there are friends of mine
who hyper focus on it and their whole
business is built by social media and
they're making a lot of money being very
successful
i will probably dedicate 80 of their
bandwidth to that so to do social media
well you have to really focus on it and
that's why companies like bodega other
companies you know we we have a team
that just does social media so bodegas
followers modega social media is
incredible
but it's because we literally have i
don't know probably four people that's
all they do is just social media and
content and new content and building up
so i love it personally but i really
show off
you know what my family and my friends
and and and like my clean life in a way
i i should spend more time doing it
because i do some pretty incredible
stuff
and my days are
filled very very much that if i actually
film just what i do
i think people actually enjoy seeing it
so the answer is i should do better at
it
i think on social media there's always
that fine line right like i don't i
personally don't like you know posting
you know certain things that are just a
little a little out there right like
remember there's still a war going on in
this world there's still people who
can't do things right there's still
inflation like i think there's that fine
line between
you know social media using as like a
flex just to show off there's also
social media that is you know good
content so i look at it as there's
if it's your business do it works i
personally love
show my friends what i'm doing and my
family my kids
i don't like the you know airplane post
i don't like that stuff like you'll
never see me it makes you feel weird
yeah like either post he's always asking
me adam like adam should i post i'm like
yeah positive guy
i'm telling you he's constantly asking
me should i post it should i not post
this i was like hell yeah bro you're in
a private jet that you own like go for
it he's like yeah no weirdo
you know i i because the truth is that
much more like the other day i was
flying and my daughter lucy was
beautiful she was in my lap and somebody
took a picture of us it was the most
beautiful picture of us
and i said i want to post this like but
you know what i don't want it to look so
to me like i personally don't do the
do the jets and the boats and like all
that
you know crazy stuff it's not for me but
it does work for a lot of people some
people
see that and they're like wow so the
answer is i love social media i think
people who use it as a tool
keep going it works i probably should
focus a bit more on it make myself a
little more out there but to be honest
i'm also busy all day where my brain
isn't on what do you need to do that for
people you're actually right you
have no like you who you are does not
relate enough to your brand for that it
is detrimental if you don't adam's point
my five or six thousand followers when i
actually do post meetings on my kids i
will get
three thousand because they're people
who like you and know you personally
because you've kept a small group on
your social media that's true you know
people who have money don't need clout
right and that's what there is yeah yeah
there it is and it's right back to the
airplane thing like i i i mean i don't
know it's my third airplane and i've
never posted myself an airplane one time
i've never posted like new airplane like
that's not my thing some people do it
because you're not the tinder swindler
that's true
people who post pictures of their planes
i don't believe they if i had my
instagram account working right now i
would 100 and take a picture of me and
you on your airplane and by the way
i would but but instagram still disabled
my account so this instagram is fun
about it i always said it
guys that post their airplanes a lot
always look at the seats they're always
different right because it's not their
airplane yeah they're wrenching so
what's the technique to understanding if
it's someone's plane or not like if it's
the same seat
same thing i fly it's the same seat
that's your seat no i mean it could be
any seat but but but they all look yes
but the seats look the same right it's
the same upholstery
if it's in a different plane
it's a different seat ah
so we just got you guys so you see these
guys like you know taking off on the
airplane look at this seat is it beige
is it white then look at the next one
they post so the truth is again like
again but people you know that that's
just where we live in today but for me
to answer the question i use social
media for my good friends and family to
see what i'm doing
[Music]